let me ask you a question about what's
going on right now
okay long beach la uh that gets 40
percent of all imports in america comes
through long beach long beach and la
right and the prices have gone up from
2000 to 25 000 thirty thousand one guy
was talking about in 60 minutes this
sunday i don't know if you guys saw the
60 minutes about the whole what's going
on with the ports he says i have a
million dollars that i have to spend on
the on the containers he says i can't
take it out but they're forcing me to
pay the rent even though i have no way
of taking it out right now right okay
here's a question for you what
percentage of the tariffs on china are
still on
what percent of tariffs we have not
removed any tariffs on china all the
tariffs are still there right correct
okay fantastic which sticks it to
american companies i want to ask you
guys a crazy question and you tell me
i'm actually going to be curious to know
what you guys going to say about this
this port situation is worse than we
think it is christmas is going to be a
weird christmas while you're buying
gifts you ain't going to get the stuff
that you want to get if you haven't
started christmas shopping folks you're
probably not going to get the gift you
want to get for your friends you're
probably going to be christmas shopping
at cvs and getting some shitty gift for
your family and whatever's left over for
you because that's what ends up
happening
you're for gift cards everything's gonna
be a gift card season yeah hey never
mind christmas we can't get building
supplies but we couldn't do it with our
building that's why we just bought a
different building so we got two
buildings we're buying instead of one
because we can't get glass it's all
there it's just on a boat anchored off
of london anyways this is the point i'm
trying to make to here's a question i
got for you i'm so curious to know what
you guys are going to say i am so
curious to know what you guys are going
to say
so if
this massive crisis we have at the ports
that's taking place
what has biden done about it
i'm curious what's biden done about it
what phone call has biden made to china
what phone call has kamala made to china
schumer police she's not allowed to make
calls but i'm asking a serious question
i'm not being sarcastic i'm not being
condescending i'm asking a very serious
question this is not a policy this is a
catastrophic event that's taking place
in america today this is not a small
issue they're just not if this was the
other administration every second would
be hearing about what's going on at the
port right but it's not every second
right
if
biden could what could biden do to do
right now to make the phone call he's
done nothing so here's my trick question
for you let's see what you're going to
say
and see if you already know where this
question is going if your friend
djt
was president today okay if your body
you guys are from the same area florida
whatever
if your body was a president today do
you think he makes a phone call to china
are you saying that biden hasn't spoken
to she if he has spoken to she has
anything changed no they actually did
finally they just said to each other
what's changed nothing i think the call
was like last week you and i can talk
for three hours and we can shoot the
[ __ ] and nothing gets done i don't think
buying first year shooting the [ __ ] oh
so what are they doing so so you but
here's what i'm asking you here if trump
was president and you find that this is
going on at the ports and they're
raising prices from two to twenty five
thousand dollars from two to twenty five
thousand dollars hurting the small
business owner where that price of two
to twenty five gets passed down to
middle america because the guy said i
have to raise my prices
if if djt the most hated president of
the last 40 years most controversial
president of the last 40 years
like him or hate him if he was president
today would he make that phone call and
what would have happened the answer is
yes or no what he made the phone call we
have called china and done something to
expedite the process and cheapened the
cost of this had some dialogue dialogue
is good do you think more progress would
have been made where we're i don't know
i don't know are you really saying you
don't know are you are you telling me to
say you want me to say yes no no no no
no no no i got it done no no no no no
it's not about you yeah it's time let's
go let me let me let me just ask this
question
let me just ask this question what don't
we understand biden spoke to sheep for
20 hours he made the call tom what are
we talking about adam let me go to the
question for you here let me ask the
question in a different way say
clinton's the president
can you the guy you like this isn't like
to say bush is the president say
reagan's the president say jfk is the
president say any of these guys are the
president
do you not think a phone call would be
made right now to figure something out
fyi you can't say the answer you don't
know what trump would have done you had
four years of track record to say what
he would have done do you think he would
have called china and said hey if you
raise these container prices one more
time 25 tariff 35 tariff you think he
would have done that you think he would
have done that you think now that china
is the richest country in the world
richard and us you think he would be
okay that happened during his
administration wouldn't be happening
he'd be making a phone call china's
sitting there saying freaking awesome
give us more money these guys are idiots
they're letting us do it china is
they're really taking they're taking
advantage of
the absolute it doesn't matter what
subject you're talking about the biden
administration is paralyzed it doesn't
you fill in the blank they're paralyzed
paralyzed paralyzed paralyzed they can't
get anything done
and this is frightening i mean you you
had
in in 2019 you had more than a thousand
trucking companies go out of business in
2020 you had like 3200 trucking
companies go out of business mostly
small mom and pops why haven't
regulations been ripped back immediately
to make life on truckers easier why
this
we're talking about executive order
stuff here just get out your damn pain
and sign it
i mean why haven't we seen more
executive orders period out of biden
that was the whole complaint with biden
that he did too many executive orders at
the beginning of his process when was
the last time he got out how long did it
take him to sign the infrastructure bill
so that he could have this huge ceremony
on monday and then go to some bridge
that's falling down and try and quote
unquote zelda legislation after it had
passed what the hell's up with that
buddy i don't need you to go do some
ribbon-cutting ceremony i need you to be
president of the country when it's being
eaten alive by inflation do something
so what do you think he is actually
doing no no no wait wait wait adam i
don't think we can ask the question
nobody no one's given my answer i asked
a question here's my question to you if
trump's president today
if desantis is president today if
manchin is president today pick any of
these guys but specifically to trump
because we got four years of track
record that's what i'm specifically
asking about if he was president today
how would he end handle what's going on
with china i'm curious what do you think
you're saying i don't know very naive
answer you're a smart guy i'm saying
that what do you think you would you
framed the question what do you think
what you should have done he made a
phone call they spoke to sheep for three
hours your framing is if you didn't
speak nothing happens i'm asking you
what what would trump have done if he
was president today in regards to china
and the [ __ ] show we have at the ports
i'm sure he would do something about it
like whether it was good it should be
something there would have been
bombastic i'm sure you would have
threatened
whatever do you think china would be a
little bit more careful to bump up
prices 60 minutes the guy says
he says the the 60 minutes guys what's
the name not lester holt what is the
guys anyway the 60 minute guy he speaks
very calm he says do you think china is
taking advantage of the crisis and
raising up prices on containers because
they can't
here's a guy's answer he says it
certainly feels like it
adam from two to twenty five thousand
from two to twenty five thousand dollars
adam who produces ninety percent of the
containers in the world
china china china manufactures ninety
percent of the containers in the world
okay so what should be done
what should be done i'll answer the
question
let me ask patrick's question a
different way
by now would there have been
multiple delegations of of advisors on
airplanes to beijing sitting down
ripping doors open multiple meetings
saying we're going to get to the bottom
of this because you're not going to rape
our country
there would have been multiple
delegations and if there was no response
as there has not been a response all
they do is continue to raise prices if
there was no response and then there
would have been retaliation and i'm
speaking for a joe manchin i'm speaking
for a bill clinton you don't watch
what's happening to americans happen to
americans and and have your your press
secretary stand up in front of a podium
and say most economists don't see
inflation
denial is not it's not a strategy no it
was no economist no economists that live
on my floor say there's i thought that
was attached to the infrastructure bill
that's a separate question
look when she's saying saying no
economists see inflation attached to the
infrastructure or the infrastructure
building everyone sees the six percent
inflation that's a different point
i agree with it the infrastructure
bill's not because you know what joe
biden got up and said this
infrastructure spending bill is going to
create tons of union jobs it's like
saying we're officially formally
announcing to you that we're going to
piss away taxpayer money by by having
unionized positions that's what they in
the entire obamacare 600 billion dollars
whatever the hell it was it obama said
after he got out of office that it
accomplished nothing for the economy
zero zippo if you're going to do this
the way that it's always been done pork
spending
zach is right it's not going to create
inflation it's not going to create
economic output it's not going to create
[ __ ]
yeah i i i'm going to answer your
question directly please because this is
he did not i don't know
he would have threatened him he would
have done something
i don't have the answer here what trump
maybe would have done
that's a question you said what do you
guys do for thanksgiving
we answered we went through i answered
it as well i know but you haven't
answered it your answer is i i don't
know what he was trump would have made
some threats to nuke them i don't know
what would you have what are you doing
come on
sarcasm which is fantastic you know it's
great so that means you're not answering
you're copping out with me go ahead i've
answered it
stop stop stop actually i was quite
freaking cool guy so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]